The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, what I'll talk
about here is how to actually
understand the performance of
your application, and what are
some of the things you can do
to actually improve your
performance.
You're going to hear more about
automated optimizations,
compile the optimizations
on Monday.
There will be two
talks on that.
You'll get some cell-specific
optimizations that you can do,
so some cell-specific tricks on
Tuesday in the recitation.
So here, this is meant to be a
more general purpose talk on
how can you debug performance
anomalies and performance
problems. Then what are some
way that you can actually
improve the performance.
Where do you look after you've
done your parallelization.
So just to review the key
concepts to parallelism.
Coverage -- how much parallelism
do you have in
your application.
All of you know, because
you all had perfect
scores on the last quiz.
So that means if you take a look
at your program, you find
the parallel parts and that
tells you how much parallelism
that you have. If you don't
have more than a certain
fraction, there's really nothing
else you can do with
parallelism.
So the rest of the talk will
help you address the question
of well, where do you go
for last frontier.
The granularity.
We talked about how the
granularity of your work and
how much work are you doing on
each processor affects your
load balancing, and how it
actually affects your
communication costs.
If you have a lot of things
colocate on a single
processor, then you don't have
to do a whole lot of
communication across processors,
but if you
distribute things at a finer
level, then you're doing a
whole lot of communication.
So we'll look at the
communication costs again and
some tricks that you can
apply to optimize that.
Then the last thing that we had
talked about in one of the
previous lectures is locality,
in locality of communication
versus computation, and both
of those are critical.
So we'll have some
examples of that.
So just to review the
communication cost model, so I
had flashed up on the screen a
while ago this equation that
captures all the factors that
go into figuring out how
expensive is it to actually send
data from one processor
to the other.
Or this could even apply on
a single machine where a
processor is talking
to the memory --
you know, loads and stores.
The same cost model really
applies there.
If you look at how
processors --
a uniprocessor tries to improve
communication, and
some of the things we've
mentioned really early on in
the course for improving
communication costs, what we
focused on is this overlap.
There are things you can do,
for example, sending fewer
messages, optimizing how you're
packing data into your
messages, reducing the cost of
the network in terms of the
latency, using architecture
support, increasing the
bandwidth and so on.
But really the biggest impact
that you can get is really
just from overlap because you
have direct control over that,
especially in parallel
programming.
So let's look at a small review
-- you know, what did
it mean to overlap.
So we had some synchronization
point or some point in the
execution and then
we get data.
Then once the data's arrived,
we compute on that data.
So this could be
a uniprocessor.
A CPU issues a load, it goes
out to memory, memory sends
back the data, and then the
CU can continue operating.
But the uniprocessors
can pipeline.
They allow you to have
multiple loads
going out to memory.
So you can get the effect of
hiding over overlapping a lot
of that communication latency.
But there are limits to the
communication, to the
pipelining effects.
If the work that you're doing is
really equal to the amount
of data that you're
fetching, then you
have really good overlap.
So we went over this in the
recitation and we showed you
an example of where pipelining
doesn't have any performance
effects and so you might not
want to do it because it
doesn't give you the performance
bang for the
complexity you invest in it.
So, if things are really nicely
matched you get good
overlap, here you only get god
overlap -- sorry, these, for
some reason, should be
shifted over one.
So where else do you look
for performance?
So there are two kinds
of communication.
There's inherent communication
and your algorithm, and this
is a result of how you actually
partition your data
and how you partitioned
your computation.
Then there's artifacts that come
up because of the way you
actually do the implementation
and how you map it to the
architecture.
So, if you have poor
distribution of data across
memory, then you might
unnecessarily end up fetching
data that you don't need.
So, you might also have
redundant data fetchers.
So let's talk about that
in more detail.
The way I'm going to do this
is to draw from wisdom in
uniprocessors.
So in uniprocessors, CPUs
communicate with memory, and
really conceptually, I think
that's no different than
multiple processors talking
to multiple processors.
It's really all about where the
data is flowing and how
the memories are structured.
So, loads and stores are the
uniprocessor as what and what
are to distributed memory.
So if you think of Cell, what
would go in those two blanks?
Can you get this?
I heard the answer there.
You get input.
So, DMA get and DMA put.
That's really just the
load and a store.
It's just doing, instead of
loading one particular data
element, you're loading a
whole chunk of memory.
So, on a uniprocessor, how do
you overlap communication?
Well, architecture, the memory
system is designed in a way to
exploit two properties that
have been observed in
computation.
Spacial locality and temporal
locality, and I'll look at
each one separately.
So in spacial locality,
CPU asks for a
data address of 1,000.
What the memory does, it'll send
data address of 1,000,
plus a whole bunch of other data
that's neighboring to it,
so 1,000 to 1,064.
Really, how much data you
actually send, you know, what
is the granularity of
communication depends on
architectural parameters.
So in common architecture it's
really the block side.
So if you have a cache where the
organization says you have
a block side to 32 words, 32
bytes, then this is how much
you transfer from main
memory to the caches.
So this works well when the CPU
actually uses that data.
If I send you 64 data bytes and
I only use one of them,
then what have I done?
I've wasted bandwidth.
Plus, I need to store all that
extra data in the cache so
I've wasted my cache capacity.
So that's bad and you
want to avoid it.
Temporal locality is
a clustering of
references in time.
So if you access some particular
data element, then
what the memory assumes is
you're going reuse that data
over and over and over again, so
it stores it in the cache.
So your memory hierarchy has
the main memory at the top
level, and that's your
slowest memory
but the biggest capacity.
Then as you get closer and
closer to the processor, you
end up with smaller caches --
these are local, smaller
storage, but they're faster.
So, if you reuse a data element
then it gets cached at
the lowest data level, and so
the assumption there is that
you're gonna reuse it over
and over and over again.
If you do that, then what
you've done is you've
amortized the cost of bringing
in that data over many, many
references.
So that works out really well.
But if you don't reuse that
particular data elements over
and over again, then you've
wasted cache capacity.
You still need to fetch the data
because the CPU asks for
it, but you might not have had
the cache, so that would have
created more space in your cache
to have something else
in there that might have
been more useful.
So in the multiprocessor case,
how do you reduce these
artifactual costs in
communication.
So, DCMA gets inputs on the
cell, or just in just message
passing, you're exchanging
messages.
Typically, you're communicating
over a course or
large blocks of data.
What you're usually getting is
a continuous chunk of memory,
although you could do some
things in software or in
hardware to gather data from
different memory locations and
pack them into contiguous
locations.
The reason you pack them into
contiguous locations again to
export spatial locality when
you store the data locally.
So to exploit the spatial
locality characteristics, what
you want to make sure is that
you actually are going to have
good spatial locality in your
actual computation.
So you want things that are
iterating over loops with
well-defined indices with
indices that go over very
short ranges, or they're very
sequential or have fixed
striped patterns where you're
not wasting a lot of the data
that you have brought in.
Otherwise, you have to
essentially just increase your
communication because every
fetch is getting you only a
small fraction of what
you actually need.
So, intuitively this
should make sense.
Temporal locality just says I
brought in some data and so I
want to maximize this utility.
So if I have any computation in
a parallel system, I might
be able to reorder my tasks in
a way that I have explicit
control over the scheduling --
which stripe executes when.
Then you want to make sure that
all the computation that
needs that particular data
happens adjacent in time or in
some short time window so that
you can amortize the cost.
Are those two concepts clear?
Any questions on this?
So, you've done all of that.
You've parallelized your code,
you've taken care of your
communication costs, you've
tried to reduce
it as much as possible.
Where else can you look for
performance -- things just
don't look like they're
performing as
well as they could?
So, the last frontier is
perhaps single thread
performance, so I'm going
to talk about that.
So what is really
a single thread.
So if you think of what you're
doing with parallel
programming, you're taking a
bunch of tasks -- this is the
work that you have to do -- and
you group them together
into threads or the equivalent
of threads, and some threads
will run on individual cores.
So essentially you have one
thread running on a core, and
if that performance goes fast,
then your overall execution
can also benefit from that.
So, that's single thread
performance.
So if you look at a timeline,
here you have sequential code
going on, then we hit some
parallel part of the
computation.
We have multiple executions
going on.
Each one of these is a
thread of execution.
Really, my finish line depends
on who's the longest thread,
who's the slowest one to
complete, and that's going to
essentially control
my speed up.
So I can improve this by doing
better load balancing.
If I distribute the
work [? so that ?]
everybody's doing equivalent
amount of work, then I can
shift that finish line
earlier in time.
That can work reasonably well.
So we talked about load
balancing before.
We can also make execution
on each processor faster.
If each one of these threads
finishes faster or I've done
the load balancing and now I
can even squeeze out more
performance by shrinking each
one of those lines, then I can
get performance improvement
there as well.
So that's improving single
thread performance.
But how do we actually
understand what's going on?
How do I know where
to optimize?
How do I know how long each
thread is taking?
How do I know how long
my program is taking?
Where are the problems?
So, there are performance
monitoring tools that hard
designed to help you do that.
So what's the most
coarse-grained way of figuring
out how long your
program took?
You have some sample piece of
code shown over here, you
might compile it, and then you
might just use time --
standard units command say run
this program and tell me how
much time it took to run.
So you get some alpha back from
time that said you took
about two seconds of user time,
this is actual code, you
took some small amount of time
in system code, and this is
your overall execution, this is
how much of the processor
you actually use.
So, a 95% utilization.
Then you might apply
some optimization.
So here we'll use the compiler,
we'll change the
optimization level, compile
the same code, run it, and
we'll see wow, performance
improved.
So we increased 99% utilization,
my running time
went down by a small chunk.
But did we really learn
anything about
what's going on here?
There's some code going on,
there's a loop here, there's a
loop here, there's some
functions with more loops.
So where is the actual
computation time going?
So how would I actually go
about understanding this?
So what are some tricks you
might have used in trying to
figure out how long something
took in your computation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you might have a timer, you
record the time here, you
compute and then you stop the
timer and then you might
printout or record how
long that particular
block of code took.
Then you might have a histogram
of them and then you
might analyze the histogram to
find out the distribution.
You might repeat this over and
over again for many different
loops or many different
parts that are code.
If you have a preconceived
notion of where the problem is
then you instrument that
and see if your
hypothesis is correct.
That can help you identify the
problems. But increasingly you
can actually get more accurate
measurements.
So, in the previous routine,
you're using the time, you
were looking at how much time
has elapsed in seconds or in
small increments.
But you can actually use
hardware counters today to
actually measure clock
cycles, clock ticks.
That might be more useful.
Actually, it's more useful
because you can measure a lot
more events than just
clock ticks.
The counters in modern
architectures are really
specialized registers that count
up events and then you
can go in there and probe and
ask what is the value in this
register, and you can
use that as part of
your performance tuning.
You use them much in the same
way as you would have done to
start a regular timer or
stop a regular timer.
There are specialized
libraries that run.
Unfortunately, these are very
architecture-specific at this point.
There's not really a common
standard that says grab a
timer at each different
architecture in a uniform way,
although that's getting
better with some
standards coming out from--.
I'll talk about that in
just a few slides.
You can use this to, for
example, measure your
communication to computation
cost. So you can wrap your DMA
get and DMA put by timer calls,
and you can measure
your actual work by timer calls,
and figuring out how
much overlap can you get from
overlap in communication and
communication computation and
is that really worthwhile to
do pipelining.
But this really requires
manual changes to code.
You have to go in there
and start the timers.
You have to have maybe an idea
of where the problem is, and
you have the Heisenberg
effect.
If you have a loop and you want
to measure code within
the loop because you have a
nested loop inside of that,
then now you're effecting the
performance of the outer loop.
That can be problematic.
So it has a better effect
because you can't really make
an accurate measurement on the
thing you're inspecting.
So there's a slightly better
approach, dynamic profiling.
Dynamic profiling is really
there's an event-based
profiling and time-based
profiling.
Conceptually they do
the same thing.
What's going on here is your
program is running and you're
going to say I'm interested in
events such as cache misses.
Whenever n number of cache
misses happen, let's say
1,000, let me know.
So you get an interrupt
whenever 1,000
cache misses happen.
Then you can update a counter
or use that to trigger some
optimizations or analysis.
This works really nicely because
you don't have to
touch your code.
You essentially run your program
as you normally do
with just one modification
that includes running the
dynamic profiler, as well as
your actual computation.
As far as multiple languages
because all it does is just
takes your binary so you can
program in any language, any
programming model.
It's quite efficient to actually
use these dynamic
profiling tools.
The sampling frequencies are
reasonably small, you can make
them reasonably small and still
have it be efficient.
So some counter examples.
Clock cycles, so you can
measure clock ticks.
Pipeline stalls.
This might be interesting if
you want to optimize your
instruction schedule -- you'll
actually see this in the
recitation next week.
Cache hits, cache misses -- you
can get an idea of how bad
your cache performance is and
how much time you're spending
in the memory system.
Number of instructions, loads,
stores, floating
point ops and so on.
Then you can derive some useful
measures from that.
So I can get an idea of
processor utilization --
divide cycles by time and that
gives me utilization.
I can derive some other things
and maybe some of the more
interesting things like
memory of traffic.
So how much data am I actually
sending between a CPU and a
processor, or how much data am
I communicating from one
processor to the other.
So I can just grab the counters
for number of loads
and number of stores, figure out
what the cache line size
is -- usually those are
documented or there are
calibration tools you can run
to get that value, and you
figure out memory of traffic.
Another one would be
bandwidth consumed.
So bandwidth is memory of
traffic per second.
So how would you measure that?
It's just the traffic divided
by the wall clock time.
There's some others that
you can calculate.
So these can be really useful
in helping you figure out
where are the things you
should go focus in on.
I'm going to show you
some examples.
The way these tools work is
you have your application
source code, you compile
it down to a binary.
You take your binary and you
run it, and then that can
generate some profile that
stores locally on your disk.
Then you can take that profile
and analyze it by some sort of
interpreter, and some cases you
can actually analyze the
binary as well, and reannotate
your source code.
That can actually be very useful
because it'll tell you
this particular line of your
code is the one where you're
spending most of your
time computing.
So some tools -- have any
of you used these tools?
Anybody use Gprof,
for example?
Good.
So, you might have an idea of
how these could be used.
There are others.
HPCToolkit, which I commonly
use from Rice.
Pappy is very common because it
has a very nice interface
for grabbing all kinds
of counters.
VTune from Intel, and there's
others that work in different
ways and so there are binary
instrumenters that do the same
things and do it slightly more
efficiently and actually give
you the ability to compile
your code at run time and
optimize it, taking advantage
of the profiling information
you've collected.
So here's a sample
of running Gprof.
Gprof should be available on
any Linux system, it's even
available on Cygwin,
if you see Cygwin.
I've compiled some code --
this is MPEG 2D code, a
reference implementation.
I specify some parameters
to run it.
Here I add this dash Rflag which
says use a particular
kind of inverse DCDT that's a
floating point precise that
uses double precision for
the floating point
computations in DCT --
inverse DCT rather.
So you can see actually where
most of the time is being
spent in the computation.
So here's a time per function,
so each row
represents a function.
So this is the percent of the
time, this is the actual time
in seconds, how many times I
actually called this function,
and some other useful things.
So the second function that's
used here that happens is MPEG
intrablock decoding and here
you're doing some spatial
decomposition, restoring
spatial pictures by 5%.
So if you were optimize this
particular code, where would
you go look?
You would look in the
reference DCT.
So, MPEG has two versions
of DCT --
one that uses floating point,
another that just uses some
numerical tricks to operate over
integers for a loss of
precision, but they find that
acceptable as part of this
application.
So you omit the Rflag, it
actually uses a different
function for doing the DCT.
Now you see the distribution of
where the time is spent in
your computation changes.
Now there's a new function
that's become the bottleneck
and it's called Form Component
Prediction.
Then IDCT column, which
actually is the main
replacement of the previous
code, this one, is now about
1/3 of the actual computation.
So, this could be useful because
you can Gprof your
application, figure out where
the bottlenecks are in terms
of performance, and you might
go in there and tweak the
algorithm completely.
You might go in there and sort
of look at some problems that
might be implementation bugs
or performance bugs and be
able to fix those.
Any questions on that?
You can do sort of more
accurate things.
So, Gprof largely uses one
mechanism, HPCToolkit uses the
performance counters to actually
give you more finer
grade measurements
if you want them.
So, in the HPCToolkit, you run
your program in the same way.
You have MPEG 2D code, dash dash
just says this is where
the parameters are to impact
2D code following that dash
dash, and you can add some
parameters in there that say
these are counters I'm
interested in measuring.
So the first one is
total cycles.
The second one is the L1, so
primary cache load misses.
Then you might want to count
the floating point
instructions and the
total instructions.
As you run your program you
actually get a profiling
output, and then you can process
that file and it'll
spit out some summaries
for you.
So it'll tell you this is the
total number of cycles, 698
samples with this frequency.
So if you multiply the two
together, you an idea of how
many cycles your computation
took.
How many load misses?
So it's 27 samples at
this frequency.
So remember what's going on
here is the counter is
measuring events, and when the
event reaches a particular
threshold it let's you know.
So here the sampling threshold
is 32,000.
So whenever 32,000 floating
point instructions occur you
get a sample.
So you're just counting how many
interrupts you're getting
or how many samples.
So you multiply the two
together you can
get the final counts.
It can do things like Gprof,
it'll tell you where your time
is and where you spent
most of your time.
Actually breaks it down
into your module.
So, MPEG calls some standard
libraries, libsi.
I could break it down by
functions, break it down by
line number.
You can even annotate
your source code.
So here's just a simple example
that I used earlier,
and each one of these columns
represent one of the metrics
that we measured, and you can
see most of my time is spent
here, 36% at this particular
statement.
So that can be very useful.
You can go in there and
say, I want to do some
[? dization ?], I can maybe
reduce this overhead in some
way to get better performance.
Any questions on that?
Yup.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]?
PROFESSOR: I don't know.
Unfortunately, I don't know
the answer to that.
There's some nice gooies for
some of these tools.
So VTune has a nice interface.
I use HPCViewer.
I use HPCToolkit, which provides
HPCViewer, so I just
grab the screenshot from one
of the tutorials on this.
You have your source code.
It shows you some of the same
information I had on a
previous slide, but in a
nicer graphical format.
So, now I have all this
information, how do I actually
improve the performance?
Well, if you look at what is
the performance time on a
uniprocessor, it's time spent
computing plus the time spent
waiting for data or
waiting for some
other things to complete.
You have instructional level
parallels, which is really
critical for uniprocessors,
and architect that sort of
spent massive amounts of effort
in providing multiple
functional units,
deeply pipeline
the instruction pipeline.
Doing things like speculation,
prediction to keep that
instructional level of
parallelism number high so you
can get really good
performance.
You can do things like looking
at the assembly code and
re-ordering instructions to
avoid instruction hazards in
the pipeline.
You might look at a register
allocation.
But that's really very
low-hanging fruit.
You have to reach really high
to grab that kind of fruit.
You'll actually, unfortunately,
get the
experience that is part of
the next recitation.
So apologies in advance.
But you'll see that --
well I'm not going
to talk about that.
Instead I'm going to focus about
some things that are
perhaps lower-hanging fruit.
So data level parallelism.
So we've used SIMD in
some of recitations.
I'm giving you a short
example of that.
Here, I'm going to talk about
how you actually get data
level parallelism or how do you
actually find the SIMD in
your computation so you can
get that added advantage.
Some nice things about data
level parallelism in the form
of short vector instructions
is that the harder really
becomes simpler.
You issue one instruction and
that same instruction operates
over multiple data elements
and you get
better instruction bandwidth.
I just have to fetch one
instruction and if my vector
lens is 10, than that
effectively does 10
instructions for me.
The architecture can get
simpler, reduces the
complexity.
So it has some nice
advantages.
The thing to go after is
the memory hierarchy.
This is because of that speed
gap that we showed earlier on
in the course between memory
speed and processor speed, and
if you optimize a performance
usually it's like 1%
performance and your cache
registry gives you some
significant performance
improvement in
your overall execution.
So you want to go after that
because that's the biggest
beast in the room.
A brief overview of SIMD and
then some detailed examples as
to how you actually go about
extracting short vector
instructions.
So, here we have an example
of scaleacode.
We're iterating in a loop from
zero to n, and we're just
adding some array elements a to
b and storing results in c.
So in the scaler mode, we just
have one add, each value of a
and b is one register.
We add those together,
we write the value
to a separate register.
In the vector mode, we can pack
multiple data elements,
so here let's assume our vector
lens is four, I can
pack four of these data values
into one vector register.
You can pack four of these data
elements into another
vector register, and now my
single vector instruction has
the effect of doing four ads
at th same time, and it can
store results into four
elements of c.
Any questions on that?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
We'll get to that.
So, let's look at those to sort
of give you a more lower
level feel for this.
Same code, I've just shown
data dependence graph.
I've omitted things like the
increment of the loop and the
branch, just focusing on
the main computation.
So I have two loads, one brings
a sub i, the other
brings b sub i.
I do the add and I get c sub i
and then I can store that.
So that might be sort of a
generic op code sequence that
you have. If you're scheduling
that, then in the first slot I
can do those two loads in
parallel, second cycle I can
do the add, third cycle
I can do the store.
I can further improve
this performance.
If you took 6.035 you might see
software pipelining, you
can actually overlap some
of these operations.
Not really that important
here.
So, what would the cycle or the
schedule look like on a
cycle-by-cycle basis if this
was defector output?
In the scaler case, you have
n iterations, right?
Each iteration's taking three
cycles so that's your overall
execution on time --
n times 3 cycles.
In the vector case, each load
is bringing you four data
elements, so a sub i
to a sub i plus 3.
Similarly for b.
Then you add those together.
So the schedule would look
essentially the same.
The op codes are different,
and here what your overall
execution time be?
Well, what I've done is each
iteration is now doing four
additions for me.
So if you notice, the loop
bounds have changed.
Instead of going from i to n
by increments of 1, now I'm
going by increments of 4.
So, overall, instead of having
n iterations, I can get by
with n over 4 iterations.
That make sense?
So, what would my speed
up be in this case?
4.
So you can get more and more
speed up if your vector lens
is longer, because then I can
cut down on the number of
iterations that I need.
Depending on the length of my
vector register and the data
types that I have, that
effectively gives me different
kinds of vector lens for
different data types.
So you saw on Cell you have 128
bit registers and you can
pack those with bytes,
characters, bytes, shorts,
integers, floats or doubles.
So each one of those gives you
different kinds of a different
vector lens.
SIMD is really now, SIMD
extensions are
increasingly popular.
They're available on
a lot of ISAs.
Alt of x, MMX, SSE
are available
on a lot x86 machines.
And, of course, in Cell, in
fact, on the SPU, all your
instructions are SIMD
instruction, and when you're
doing a scaler instruction,
you're actually using just one
chunk of your vector register
and your vector pipeline.
So how do you actually use
these SIMD instructions?
Unfortunately, it's library
calls or using inline assembly
or using intrinsics.
You'll get hands-on experience
with this with Cell, so you
might complain about that
when you actually do it.
Compile technology is actually
getting better, and you'll see
that one of the reasons we're
using an XLC compiler is
because it has these vector data
types, which also latest
versions of GCC have that allow
you to express data
types as vector data types,
and the compiler can more
easily or more naturally get the
parallelism for you, SIMD
parallelism with you having to
go in there and do it by hand.
But if you were to do it by
hand, or, in fact, what the
compilers are trying to
automate are different
techniques for looking for where
the SIMD parallelism is.
There was some work done here
about six years ago by Sam
Larson, who is now graduated,
on super word level
parallelism.
so I'm going to focus the rest
of this talk on this concept
of SIMDization because I think
it's probably the one that's
most useful for extracting
parallelism in some of the
codes that you're doing.
So this is really ideal for
SIMD where you have really
short vector lens, 2 to 8.
What you're looking for is
SIMDization that exists within
a basic block.
So within a code block, within
a body of a loop or within
some control flow even.
You can uncover this with simple
analysis, and this
really has pushed the boundary
on what automatic
compilers can do.
Some of work that's gone on
at IMB, what they call the
octipiler, has eventually been
transferred to the XLC
compiler do a lot of defecniques
that build on SLP
and expand in various ways to
broaden the scope of what you
can automatically parallize.
So here's an example of how
you might actually derive
SIMDization or opportunities
for SIMDization.
So you have some code, let's
say you're doing RGB
computations where you're just
adding the r elements, that's
a red, green and blue.
So this might be in a loop, and
what you might notice it
well I can pack the RGB elements
into one register.
I can pack these into another
register, and I can pack these
literals into a third
register.
So that gives me a way to pack
data together into SIMD
registers, and now I can replace
this scaler code with
instructions that pack
the vector register.
I can do the computations
in parallel and
I can unpack them.
We'll talk about that with a
little bit more illustration
in a second.
Any questions on this?
Perhaps the biggest improvement
that you can get
from SIMDization is by looking
at adjacent memory references.
Rather than doing one load you
can do a vector load, which
really gives you a bigger
bandwidth to memory.
So in this case, I have a load
from I1, I2, and since these
memory locations are continuous,
I can replace them
by one vector load that brings
in all these data
elements in one shot.
That essentially eliminates
three load instructions, which
are potentially most heavy
weight for one ligher weight
instruction because it amortizes
bandwidth and
exploits things like
spatial locality.
Another one, vectorizable
loops.
So this is probably one of
the most advanced ways of
exploiting SIMDization,
especially in really long
vector codes, so traditional
supercomputers like the Cray,
and you'll probably hear Simmon
talk about this in the
next lecture.
So I have some loop
and I hvae this
particular statement here.
So how can I get SIMD
code out of this?
Anybody have any ideas?
Anybody know about
loop unrolling?
So if I unroll this loop, I
essentially -- that same trick
that I had shown earlier,
although I didn't
quite do it this way.
I change a loop bound
from n to --
the increment from -- rather
than stepping through one at a
time, stepping through
four at a time.
Now the loop body, rather than
doing one addition at a time,
I'm doing four additions
at a time.
So now this is very natural for
a vectorization, right?
Vector load, vector load, vector
store plus the vector
add in the middle.
Is that intuitive?
So this gives you another way
of extracting parallelism.
Looking at traditional loops,
seeing whether you can
actually unroll it in different
ways, be able to get
that SIMD parallelization.
The last one I'll talk about
is about partial
vectorization.
Either it might be some things
where you have a mix of
statements.
So here I have a loop where I
have some load and then I'm
doing some computation here.
So what could I do here?
It's not as symmetric
as the other loop.
AUDIENCE: There's no vector
and [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you might omit that.
But could you do anything
about the subtraction?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: If I can unroll
this again, right?
Now there's no dependencies
between this instruction and
this instruction, so I can
really move these together,
and once I've moved these
together then these loads
become contiguous.
These loads are contiguous so I
can replace these by vector
codes, vector equivalents.
So now the vector load bring
in L0, L1, I have the
addition, that brings in those
two elements in a vector, and
then I can do my scaler
additions.
But what do I do about the
value getting out of this
vector register into this scaler
register that I need
for the absolute values.
So this is where the benefits
versus cost of
SIMDization come in.
So the benefits are great
because you can replace
multiple instructions by one
instruction, or you can just
cut down the number of
instructions by specific
factor, your vector lens.
Low stores can be replaced by
one wide memory operation, and
this is probably the biggest
opportunity for performance
improvements.
But the cost is that you have
to pack data into the data
registers an you have to unpack
it out so that you can
have those kinds of
communications between this
vector register here and the
value here, this value here
and this value here.
Often you can't simply access
vector values without doing
this packing and unpacking.
So how do you actually do
the packing, unpacking?
This is predominantly where a
lot of the complexity goes.
So the value of a here is
initialized by some function
and the value of b here is
initialized by some function,
and these might not be
things that I can
SIMdize very easily.
So what I need to do is move
that value into the first
element of vector register, and
move the second value into
the second element of
the vector register.
So if I have a four-way vector
register, then I have to do
four of these moves, and that
essentially is the packing.
Then I could do my vector
computation, which is really
these two statements here.
Then eventually I have to do my
unpacking because I have to
get the values out to do this
operation and this operation.
So there's an extraction
that has to happen
out of my SIMD register.
But you can amortize the cost
of the packing and unpacking
by just reusing your
vector registers.
So these are like register
allocation techniques.
So if I pack things into a
vector register, I find all
cases where I can actually reuse
that vector register and
I try to find opportunities
for extra SIMDization.
So in the other case then, I
pack one then I can reuse that
same vector register.
So what are some ways I can look
for to amortize the cost?
The interesting thing about
memory operations is while
there are many different ways
you can pack scaler values
into a vector register, there's
really only one way
you can pack loads coming in
from memory into a vector
register is because you want
the loads to be sequential,
you want to exploit the
spatial locality.
So one vector load really gives
you specific ordering.
So, that really constrains
you in various ways.
So you might bend over backwards
in some cases to
actually get your code to
be able to you reuse the
wide-word load without having
to do too much packing or
unpacking because that'll start
eating into your benefits.
So simple example of how
you might find the SLP
parallelism.
So the first thing you want to
do is start with are the
instructions that give you the
most benefit, so it's memory
references.
So here there are two
memory references.
They happen to be adjacent, so
I'm accessing a contiguous
memory chunks, so I can
parallelized that.
That would be my first step.
I can do a vector load and
that assignment can
become a and b.
I can look for opportunities
where I can propagate this
vector values within the
vector register that's
holding a and b.
So the way I do that is I look
for uses of a and b.
In this case, there are
these two statements.
So I can look for opportunities
to vectorize that.
So in this case, both of these
instructions are also
vectorizable.
Now I have a vector subtraction,
and I have a
vector register holding
new values h and j.
So I follow that chain again
of where data's flowing.
I find these operations and I
can vectorize that as well.
So, sign up with a vectorizable
loop where all my
instructions, all my scale
instructions are now in SIMD
instructions.
I can cut down on loop
iterations of total number of
instructions that I issue.
But I've made some implicit
assumption here.
Anybody know what it is?
AUDIENCE: Do you actually
need that many
iterations of the loop?
PROFESSOR: Well, so you can
factor down the cost. so here
I've vectorized by 2, so I would
cut down the number of
iterations by 2.
AUDIENCE: You could have an
odd number of iterations?
PROFESSOR: Right, so you could
have an odd number of
iterations.
What do you do about the
remaining iterations.
You might have to do scaler
code for that.
What are some other
assumptions?
Maybe it will be clear here.
So in vectorizing this, what
have I assumed about
relationships between
these statements?
I've essentially reorganized
all the statements so that
assumes I have this liberty to
move instructions around.
Yup?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
a and b don't change
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So there's nothing in here
that's changing the values.
There's no dependencies between
these statements -- no
flow dependencies and no other
kind of constraints that limit
this kind of movement.
So in real code it's not
actually the case.
You end up with patterns of
computation where you can get
really a nice case of classic
cases you can vectorize those
really nicely.
In a lot of other codes you
have a mix of vectorizable
code and scaler code and there's
a lot of communication
between the two.
So the cost is really something
significant that you
have to consider.
This was, as I mentioned, done
in somebody's Masters thesis
and eventually led to some
additional work that was his
PhD thesis.
So in some of the early work,
what he did was he looked at a
bunch of benchmarks and looked
at how much available
parallelism you have in terms
of this kind of short vector
parallelism, or rather SLP
where you're looking for
vectorizable code within basic
blocks, which really differed
from a classic way of people
looking for vectorization.
[? And you ?] have
well-structured loops and
doing kinds of transformations
you'll hear about next week.
So for different kinds of vector
registers, so these are
your vector lens.
So going from 128 bits to 1,024
bits, you can actually
reduce a whole lot
of instructions.
So what I'm showing here
is the percent dynamic
instruction reduction.
So if I take my baseline
application and just compile
it in a normal way and I run it
again an instruction count.
I apply this SLP technique that
find the SIMDization and
then run my application again,
use the performance counters
to count the number
of instructions
and compare the two.
I can get 60%, 50%, 40%.
In some cases I can completely
eliminate almost 90% or more
of the instructions.
So it's a lot of opportunity for
performance improvements
that might be apparent.
One because I'm reducing the
instruction bandwidth, I'm
reducing the amount of space I
need in my instruction cache,
I have fewer instructions so I
can fit more instructions into
my instruction cache, you reduce
the number of branches.
You get better bandwidth to the
memory, better use of the
memory bandwidth.
Overall, you're running fewer
iterations, so you're getting
lots of potential
for performance.
So, I actually ran this
on the AltiVec.
This was one of the earliest
generations of AltiVec, which
SIMD instructions didn't have
I believe double precision
floating point, so not all the
benchmarks you see on the
previsou slide are here, only
the ones that could run
reasonably accurately
with a single
precision floating point.
What they measure is the
actual speed up.
Doing this SIMDization versus
not doing a SIMDization, how
much performance you can get.
The thing to take away is in
some cases where you have
nicely structured loops and some
nice patterns, you can
get up to 7x speed up
on some benchmarks.
What might be the maximum speed
up that you can get
depends on the vector lens,
so 8, for example on some
architectures depending
on the data type.
Is there any questions
on that?
So as part of the next
recitation, you'll actually
get an exercise of going through
and SIMDizing for
Cell, and whether that actually
means SIMDize
instructions for Cell might take
statements and sort of
replace them by intrinsic
functions, which eventually
map down to actually assembly
op codes that you'll need.
So you don't actually have to
program at the assembly level,
although in effect, you're
probably doing the same thing.
Last thing we'll talk about
today is optimizing for the
memeory hierarchy.
In addition to data level
parallelism, looking for
performance enhancements in the
memory system gives you
the best opportunities because
of this big gap in performance
between memory access latencies
and what the CPU
efficiency is.
So exploiting locality in
a memroy system is key.
So these concepts of temporal
and spatial locality.
So let's look at an example.
Let's say I have a loop and in
this loop I have some code
that's embodied in some function
a, some code embodied
in some function b, and some
code in some function c.
The values produced by a are
consumed by the function b,
and similarly the values
consumed by b
are consumed by c.
So this is a general data flow
graph that you might have for
this function.
Let's say that all the data
could go into a small array
that then I can communicate
between functions.
So if I look at my actual cache
size and how the working
set of each of these functions
is, so let's say this is my
cache size -- this is how
many instructions I can
pack into the cache.
Looking at the collective number
of instructions in each
one of these functions,
I overflow that.
I have more instructions
I can fit into my
cache any one time.
So what does that mean for my
actual cash performance?
So when I run a, what do I
expect the cache hit and miss
rate behavior to be like?
So in the first iteration, I
need the instructions for a.
I've never seen a before so I
have to fetch that data from
memory and put in the cache.
So, the attachments.
So what about b?
Then c?
Same thing.
So now I'm back at the
top of my loop.
So if everything fit in
the cache then I would
expect a to be a what?
You'll be a hit.
But since I've constrained this
problem such that the
working set doesn't really fit
in the cache, what that means
is that I have to fetch some
new instructions for a.
So let's say I have
to fetch all the
instructions for a again.
That leads me to another miss.
Now, bringing a again into my
cache kicks out some extra
instructions because I need to
make room in a finite memory
so I kick out b.
Bring in b and I end
up kicking out c.
So you end up with a pattern
where everything is a miss.
This is a problem because the
way the loop is structured,
collectively I just can't pack
all those instructions into
the cache, so I end up taking
a lot of cache misses and
that's bad for performance.
But I can look at an
alternative way
of doing this loop.
I can split up this loop into
three where in one loop I do
all the a instructions, in the
second loop I do all the b's,
and the third loop
I do all the c's.
Now my working set
is really small.
So the instructions for a fit in
the cache, instructions for
b fit in the cache, and
instructions for
c fit in the cache.
So what do I expect for the
first time I see a?
Miss.
Then second time?
It'll be hit, because I've
brought in a, I haven't run b
or c yet, the number of
instructions I need for a is
smaller than what I
can fit into the
cache, so that's great.
Nothing gets kicked out.
So every one of those
iterations
for a becomes a hit.
So that's good.
I've improved performance.
For b I have the same pattern.
First time I see b it's a miss,
every time after that
it's a hit.
Similarly for c.
So my cache miss rate goes from
being one, everything's a
miss, to decreasing to 1 over
n where n is essentially how
much I can run the loop.
So we call that full scaling
because we've taken the loop
where we've distributed, and
we've scaled every one of
those smaller loops to the
maximum that we could get.
Now what about the data?
So we have the same example.
Here we saw that the instruction
working set is
big, but what about the data?
So let's say in this case
I'm sending just a
small amount of data.
Then the behavior
is really good.
It's a small amount of data
that I need to communicate
from a to b.
A small amount of
data you need to
communicate from b to c.
So it's great.
No problems with
the data cache.
What happens in full
scaling case?
AUDIENCE: It's not correct to
communicate from a to b.
PROFESSOR: What do you mean
it's not correct?
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's not
communicating at the same time.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's not
at the same time.
In fact, just assume
this is sequential.
So I run a, I store some data,
and then when I run
b I grab that data.
This is in sequential.
AUDIENCE: How do you know that
the transmission's valid then?
We could use some
global variable.
PROFESSOR: Simple case.
There's no global variables.
All the data that b needs
comes from a.
So if I run a I produce
all the data and
that's all that b needs.
So in the full scaling case,
what do I expect to
happen for the data?
Remember, in the full scaling
case, all the working sets for
the instructions are small so
they all fit in the cache.
But now I'm running a for a lot
longer so I have to store
a lot more data for b.
Similarly, I'm running b for a
lot longer so I have to store
a lot more data for c.
So what do I expect to happen
with the working set here?
Instructions are still good,
but the data might be bad
because I've run a for a lot
more iterations at one shot.
So now I have to buffer all
this data for a to b.
Similarly, I've run b for a long
time so I have to buffer
a whole lot data for b to c.
Is that clear?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: So let's say every
time a runs it produces one
data element.
So now in this case,
every iteration
produces one data element.
That's fine.
That's clear?
Here I run a n times, so I
produce n data elements.
And b let's say produces
one data element.
So if my cache can only hold
let's say n by 2 data
elements, then there's
an overflow.
So what that means is not
everything's in the cache, and
that's bad because of the same
reasons we saw for the
instructions.
When I need those data I have
to go out to memory and get
them again, so it's extra
communication, extra
redundancy.
AUDIENCE: In this case where you
don't need to store the a
variables
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: But notice these were
sequential simple case.
I need all the data from a to
run all the iterations for b.
Then, yeah, this goes away.
So let's say this goes away,
but still b produces n
elements and that overflows
the cache.
So there's a third example where
I don't fully distribute
everything, I partially
distribute some of the loops.
I can fully scale a and b
because I can fit those
instructions in the cache.
That gets me around this
problem, because now a and b
are just communicating
one day data element.
But c is still a problem because
I still have to run b
n times in the end before I can
run c so there are n data
elements in flight.
So the data for b still becomes
a problem in terms of
its locality.
Is that clear?
So, any ideas on how
I can improve this?
AUDIENCE: assuming you have the
wrong cache line and you
have to do one or two memory
acceses to get the cache back.
PROFESSOR: So, programs
typically have really good
instruction locality just
because the nature of the way
we run them.
We have small loops and they
iterate over and over again.
Data is actually where you spend
most of your time in the
memory system.
It's fetching data.
So I didn't actually understand
why you think data
is less expensive than
instructions.
AUDIENCE: What I'm saying say
you want to read an array,
read the first, say, 8
elements to 8 words
in the cache box.
Well then you'd get 7 hits, so
every 8 iterations you have to
do a rewrite.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that assumes that you have
really good spatial locality,
because you've assumed that I've
brought in 8 elements and
I'm going to use every
one of them.
So if that's the case you have
really good spatial locality
and that's, in fact,
what you want.
It's the same kind of thing
that I showed for the
instruction cache.
The first thing is a miss,
the rest are hits.
The reason data is more
expensive, you simply have a
lot more data reads than
you have instructions.
Typically you have small
loops, hundreds of
instructions and they might
access really big arrays that
are millions of data
references.
So that becomes a problem.
So ideas on how to
improve this?
AUDIENCE: That's a loop?
PROFESSOR: That's a loop.
So what would you do in
the smaller loop?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Something
like that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So in a nested loop, you have
a smaller loop that has a
small number of iterations,
so 64.
So, 64 might be just as much as
I can buffer for the data
in the cache.
Then I wrap that loop with one
outer loop that completes the
whole number of iterations.
So if I had to do n, then
I divide n by 64.
So that can work out
really well.
So there's different kinds of
blocking techniques that you
can use on getting your data to
fit into your local store
or into your cache to exploit
these spatial and temporal
properties.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Would it not be
better to use a small
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] size so
you could run a, b, c
sequentially?
PROFESSOR: You could
do that as well.
But the problem with running a,
b, c sequentially is that
if they're in the same
loop, you end up with
instructions being bad.
That would really, this case --
so even if you change this
number you don't get around
the instructions.
So you're going to see more
optimizations that do more of
these loop tricks.
I talk about unrolling without
really defining what unrolling
is or going into a
lot of details.
Loop distribution, loop fision,
some of the things,
like loop tiling,
loop blocking.
I think Simmon's going to cover
some of these next week.
So this was implemented, this
was done by another Master
student at MIT who graduated
about two years ago, to show
that if you factor in cache
constraints versus ignoring
cache constraints, how much
performance you can get.
This was done in the context
of StreamIt.
So, in fact, some of you might
have recognized a to b to c as
being interconnected as
pipeline filters.
We ran it on different
processors, so the StrongARM
processor's really small.
InOrder processor has no L1
cache in this particular model
that we used.
But it had a really
long latency --
sorry, it had no L2 cache.
It had really long latency
to memory.
Pentium, an x86 processor.
Reasonably fast. It had a
complicated memory system and
a lot, a lot of memory overlap
in terms of references.
Then the Itanium processor,
which had a huge L2 cache at
its disposal.
So what you can see is that
lower bars indicate
bigger speed ups.
This is normalized run time.
So on the processor where you
don't actually have caches to
save you, and the memory
communication is really
expensive, you can get a lot
of benefit from doing the
cache aware scaling, that loop
nesting to take advantage of
packing instructions instead of
instruction cache, packing
data into data cache and not
having to go out to memory if
you don't to.
So you can reduce run time to
about 1/3 of what it was with
this kind of cache
optimization.
On the Pentium3 where you have
a cache to help you out, the
benefits are there, but you
don't get as big a benefit
from ignoring the cache
constraints versus being aware
of the cache constraints.
So here you're actually doing
some of that middle column
whereas here we're doing
third columns,
the cache aware fusion.
In a Itanium you really get no
benefits between the two.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain what
the left columns are?
PROFESSOR: These?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So this is tricky.
So the left columns
are doing this.
AUDIENCE: OK, sort of assuming
that icache is there.
PROFESSOR: Right, and the third
column is doing this.
So you want to do this because
the icache locality is the
best. So you always want to go
to full or maximum scaling.
I'm actually fudging a little
just for sake of clarity.
Here you're actually doing this
nesting to improve both
the instruction and
the data locality.
So you can get really good
performance improvement.
So what does that mean for
your Cell projects or for
Cell, we'll talk about that next
week at the recitation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there
some big reasons
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Well it just means
that if you have caches to
save you, and they're really big
caches and they're really
efficient, the law of
diminishing returns.
That's where profiling
comes in.
So you look at the profiling
results, you look at your
cache misses, how many cache
misses are you taking.
If it's really significant,
then you look at ways to
improve it.
If your cache misses are really
low, you missed rate is
really low, then it doesn't make
sense to spend time and
energy focusing on that.
Good question.
So, any other questions?
So summarizing the gamut of
programming for performance.
So you tune to parallelism
first, because if you can't
find the concurrency, your
Amdahl's law, you're not going
to a get a whole lot
of speed up.
But then once you figured out
what the parallelism is, then
what you want to do is really
get the performance on each
processor, the single track
performance to be really good.
You shouldn't ignore that.
The modern processors
are complex.
You need instructional level
parallelism, you need data
level parallelism, you
need memory hierarchy
optimizations, and so you
should consider those
optimizations.
Here, profiling tools could
really help you figure out
where the biggest benefits to
performance will come from.
You may have to, in fact,
change everything.
You may have to change your
algorithm, your data
structures, your program
structure.
So in the MPEG decoder case, for
example, I showed you that
if you change the flag that
says don't use double
precision inverse DCT, use a
numerical hack, then you can
get performance improvements
but you're changing your
algorithm really.
You really want to focus on just
the biggest nuggets --
where is most of the performance
coming in, or
where's the biggest performance
bottleneck, and
that's the thing you
want optimize.
So remember the law of
diminishing returns.
Don't spend your time on doing
things that aren't going to
get you anything significant
in return.
That's it.
Any questions?
OK.
How are you guys doing
with the projects?
So, one of the added benefits of
the central CBS repository
is I get notifications too
when you submit things.
So I know of only two projects
that have been submitting
things regularly.
So, I hope that'll
pick up soon.
I guess a few minutes to finish
the quiz and then we'll
see you next week.
Have a good weekend.